how should you handle cancellations and
refunds
so i got a question from one of my uh
suppliers ed
and and maybe supplier is not a great
word ed's a good friend
ed is my website hoster
so my website is is with his company
bounce web
and he wrote into me with a question and
he was asking about cancellations and
refunds and
he's he's struggling with people who
want their money back
so he has a 30-day money-back guarantee
if you're not happy to get your 30 days
you have your money back in full but
he's
he has people complaining past that 30
days people who want their money back
afterwards and to complain so
what do you do now i love ed my website
used to go down constantly from all the
traffic that we got and since moving
over to him
it hasn't gone down so for that reason
alone ed i need to do at least one video
for you
you can save my business multiple times
but ed is the guy who gets service
okay if i email ed with a question a
problem he is on it
at two in the morning whenever i need to
help he is on it doing it so
i gotta answer this question here's my
view on cancellations and refunds okay
and you know what before we get into
that let me share some beliefs that i
have
this will help guide my opinion the
first is
i don't like charging people when
they don't feel like they're getting
value okay maybe that's something
in me i like to please people i want to
feel
good about what i'm doing the service
and the products that i'm providing and
i want people to feel like they got
incredible value for what they're buying
so if somebody's buying one of my seven
dollar
zuga guides i want them to feel they're
getting way more value out of that than
the seven dollars that we're charging
and this goes all the way up to the
brands that i'm i may charge hundreds of
thousands of dollars to
for services that i'm giving them i want
i want people to be
over the moon happy with what i'm
delivering if they're not
then i'm not happy it doesn't make me
feel good okay and ed's the same kind of
guy and you should be too you shouldn't
feel happy about ripping off your
clients i don't want people to be
unhappy with
what i'm giving them the second one is i
i
hate dealing with hassle
and crap in my business
okay i try to avoid it at all costs and
a lot of times
when people write in with with
cancellation requests and they're being
you know they're just being a negative
person they're being the little man
right they're being the little man
they're hating on your business
even though you've done everything right
right you're not gonna please everybody
you're still gonna have the people
who will find a reason to hate on your
company
don't fight with them you know i don't
know
i would just give them what they want i
would give them the refund
past 30 days whatever i wouldn't care
about it
for a couple reasons one
again you don't want people to be
unhappy and it's not a marketing thing
at least for me it's not it's not a
marketing thing when i do that if i give
somebody a refund
i don't care because they're gonna go
tell their friends about
how bad it was or how great it was right
i don't care what they're gonna think
it's for me like i don't
i don't feel good with people feeling
like they didn't get
quality out of what i was creating and
the second one is that i don't want to
deal with all the negativity that comes
from
some of these customers right if
somebody's just hating on your business
and you have this rule well past 30 days
so i'm not going to give you your money
back
if you value service if you value
good relationships then having that one
customer
hate on you and fight with you
it's not just going to impact you for
that 10 minutes that you're in that
discussion
it's like the rest of your day you're
going to be thinking about this
this is going to be a cancer on the rest
of your day maybe the rest of your week
at least for me it is if i'm fighting
with somebody on something like i just
got to let this go
i don't care they can win i don't need
to win but i don't want to
think about this all week because it's
preventing me from doing
other things that are way more important
so ed if i were you
i would just give it to them
let them be happy let yourself be happy
rid yourself of the negativity that
they're dumping on your business
and focus your efforts and energies on
positive things and to make you feel
good
create amazing things and help change
the world
believe for those of you watching like
the videos
let me know what you think leave a
thumbs up below leave a comment i want
to know what you think about
cancellations
and refunds am i crazy is this what you
do
i want to know your thoughts leave it
below if you have a question for me too
you can leave it below and make a video
response
and subscribe to the channel if you want
to see more videos like this thank you
guys so much
and i'll see you soon
you